and your book uh the politics of
vulnerability how to heal Muslim
Christian relations in a post-christian
America which uh I I enjoy it I find it
very insightful in large part because my
work now is uh trying to reduce American
polarization and you make numerous
observations of the book about how we
are more polarized at any time uh since
the Civil War which I agree with and
you've been working in these spaces
you've actually walked into rooms and
kind of been like this living emblem of
trying to bridge uh the these divides
yourself
and you have a number of harrowing
stories in your book about those rooms I
mean I do and I'd be curious to hear
some of your stories
um as well I think it's a topic that
this idea of depolarization and not not
realizing that ultimately there isn't
inherent sort of moral value to
polarization which I think is actually
the way I think unfortunately a lot of
Americans have come to think about it
um that this isn't yeah polarization is
good and right because we have to oppose
those bad guys
uh you know the bad guys whoever the bad
guys are yeah and defeat being the key
word there like it's just it's not about
any way of of um talking through things
or kind of trying to find compromise
Solutions or Solutions of any sort uh it
seems like the feedback I've gotten from
people who are skeptical about my
arguments is just there is no good there
to be discovered right so I don't know
why you meaning me and keep insisting or
both of us I guess that there is
something uh valuable in the other side
right so the idea is not just that the
other side is wrong but that the other
side is fundamentally immoral evil
bigoted so on so forth and if that's the
way you're going to see your opponent
then it makes no sense to try to make
peace
um so certainly it creates uncomfortable
encounters
um and situations in which someone like
you or I
um are trying to offer another another
narrative well I've been all over the
country and there are good people
certainly of any party of any faith of
any Community I mean I'd be hard-pressed
to imagine a town where you couldn't
find someone awesome
like like there's someone awesome in
that town probably like you know almost
certainly yeah and I think there's a
realization among probably the people
you're working with and and others that
I've worked with that this is just
really bad for everyone yeah yeah I mean
the thing that you value the most is
being threatened by the state of
polarization right and again the part of
it that I look at against religion and
religious liberty which is something
that's very important to lots of people
and so I kind of started thinking about
that I was like I'm working on this
issue I realize that it's so important
to both sets of groups I'm trying to
bring together so how about I kind of
just sort of explore how this particular
issue can be the thing that kind of
makes it clearer to both sides that's
worth working together because if you
don't ultimately both sides all sides
will lose robust religious freedom
protections
um so that's what I identified so your
book talks uh about the fact that white
Evangelical Christians feel themselves
to be something of an aggrieved group uh
they're diminishing in number they feel
themselves to be diminishing in terms of
cultural importance and then that sense
of agreement can lead them to feel uh
victimized in a particular way and
marginalized and then they last lash out
um or can be
incited or inflamed by ideas that blame
their sense of diminution on another
group and then you make similar cases
about other groups including Muslim
Americans where it's like look there are
very real elements of marginalization
and so the problem is that you have this
tribalism which by the way I thought was
very vulnerable of you to characterize
the politics of vulnerability because
most people on a particular team are not
very apt to characterize the other sides
feelings of marginalization as
legitimate
and that was the key I sort of stuff I
was offering in this book kind of like
can we get to the point or even if
because a lot of people kind of hear
evangelicals or other white conservative
Christians kind of make these claims
about being victims in this country and
they the response typically is you just
roll your eyes right like it's just give
me a break you have so much power
um you're you're you were for a long I
mean for most of American history and to
some extent even today a majority in
this country how could you ever claim
victimization or minority status sorry
so these groups also claim minority
status based on the on you know
unpopularity of their traditional
beliefs and I think you know my response
to that is just like if you keep taking
that approach all you do is further
exacerbate that sense of victimization
which continues to manifest in this form
of just not even I mean the simplest
like the least worrisome version of it
is you just don't even acknowledge the
other groups have real Grievances and I
saw that time and again kind of like a
lot of commentary a lot of people are
talking to that there's nothing really
real that's bad that's happening so
Muslims
um yeah that's all just sort of
islamophobia as well you know f-a-u-x
and so it's like well if we can just get
them to start to acknowledge that that's
like the first step and the next step is
to actually understand that there might
be commonalities there there might be
some value in working with the you know
with and among these religious groups
because sometimes the feeling of
vulnerability and grievance is very much
shared
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you